so this is our standard one-bedroom and
it has a balcony we have not had any
same-sex couples but we do have family
members that are if they would would
they be accepted because we are a couple
they've been in my life since day one
and they've always been a tea Terry and
auntie Pat didn't know they were gay
till three years ago how long have you
guys been be good CC five and a half
sixty-five years all these years they've
been together and they've hid this
secret from us we're playing baseball
women didn't do that they had the
courage to do something so different in
a time when difference was not looked on
as something good
we always wore dresses you make up the
whole thing
[Music]
anybody who was not he they simply
didn't know I felt like I was sort of
living a lie I love my mother but she
put in this old me
[Music]
so you were pioneers and when it wasn't
right exactly in the forties you had to
be very careful those were the days
where buyers that were suspected of
being lesbian buyers were frequently
braided they could be arrested and
thrown in jail there are many stories
about people losing their job and
committing suicide that's a replication
of the bar raids I think love is love
and it's the most important thing what
she means to me she means everything
[Music]
we're kind of breaking the rules back
exactly
you kind of broke the rules your whole
life yes I have
I'm happy
[Music]
no regrets I'd do it all over Hey
you